Greece is set to step up its demand for
Germany to pay world war two reparations
to the sum of nearly three hundred
billion euro Athens has long been
seeking compensation for the Nazi era
occupation but Berlin says no that
that's been settled a Europe
correspondent Peter Oliver has the
latest details on this long-running saga
Europe could be set for the reopening of
some painful historical wounds the Greek
parliament has asked Germany for
billions of euro for the Nazi occupation
of the country during World War two the
demand for German war reparations is a
historical and moral debt for us it will
help us build a better future in our
relations with Germany today therefore
we have a duty to give our two peoples
the opportunity to close this chapter
Athens is next step is to send what's
known as a verbal note to Berlin that
would be seen as the starting point for
negotiations to kick off from now back
in 2016 a Greek parliamentary committee
put the figure that Berlin should pay as
reparations it well at least 290 billion
euro that's as compensation for the
deaths of tens of thousands of Greeks at
the hands of the Nazis as well as the
extortion of the Bank of Greece by
Hitler to finance his war machine
however some Greeks aren't confident
that this appeal will lead to anything
the Germans are of the opinion that it
has compensated the issue with the
payment of 160 million Deutschmarks to
the victims and the admission of about
four hundred twenty thousand guest
workers as far as the German government
too concerned that payment back in 1960
of roughly around two hundred and fifty
million euro in today's money settled
the matter once and for all we are aware
of the great guilt the attitude of the
federal government is unchanged the
question of German reparations is
settled legally and politically in the
Treaty which reunified Germany in ninth
it states that no further reparations
were planned but what to the people of
Berlin and Athens think should happen
next we have a very very big
responsibility due to world war ii but
how long are generations of generations
having to pay for things that they
didn't do as a country we have the
responsibility to react now they should
have come a little bit earlier now it's
too late they're broke and are trying to
see where they can get money of course
we should claim something not only
because many years have passed but
because of German and tolerance - do you
think we have governments that can claim
anything I think there is no political
will from any government to claim German
reparations Germany looks after its own
interests
Zenoss what are we looking after one of
the darkest periods in European history
still echoes today and ideas about what
to do when it comes to reparations for
wartime atrocities
still fairly split Peter Oliver RT
Berlin
you